after a four-hour drive kenny and i are
almost at my parents house
and it's the moment i've been waiting
for but i am freaking out
ah you okay
i'm so nervous babe
i even feel like really warm now
head up i'm nervous about
meeting armando's parents and his family
what are they going to think of me
what are they going to think of us
together
it's a lot riding on both of our
shoulders that this goes well
oh my god who are all these people
isabelle okay that's a lot of people
they're all looking and they're all
lined up
it's a very difficult moment i'm
concerned that
and my parents see us that they might
not be as accepting or kind of backtrack
on everything
you okay yeah
but not accepting him is not accepting
me
[Music]
i'm excited to see hannah again i've
missed her a lot
[Music]
this is debbie
we get out of the car and out comes
running hannah
you look beautiful and she comes right
over to me
and gives me a great big hug and it was
just wonderful seeing her again
it's good to see you hello
it's all worth it just to see her shine
and to just hug her
and love her
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you